aus für gorleben und neuer streit ums
endlager für atommüll
nach einer wissenschaftlichen studie
kommt halb deutschland infrage
machtkampf in der pandemie madrid ist
die korona hauptstadt europas auch weil
die politiker dort streiten was zu tun
ist und viele fragen an donald trump der
us-präsident soll jahrelang keine
steuern gezahlt haben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend ihnen allen und willkommen
heute um 7 geben sie uns 20 minuten für
den überblick über diesen nachrichten
tag katja stresow ist auch hier für den
sport mit der nächsten trainerentlassung
schön genannt wohin soll der radioaktiv
verstrahltem müll in deutschland diese
frage beschäftigt uns seit jahrzehnten
und weil es im grunde eine entscheidung
für die ewigkeit ist wird es darum auch
weiter viel streit geben heute zwei
nachrichten dazu der standort gorleben
der wie kein zweiter für die anti
atomkraft bewegung steht ist aus dem
rennen und etwa die hälfte der
bundesrepublik kommt aus rein
geologischer sicht für so ein endlager
in betracht
noch ist nichts entschieden aber es gibt
jetzt einen zwischenbericht von
wissenschaftlern der bundes gesellschaft
für endlagerung und darin 90 gebiete die
grundsätzlich infrage kämen
verteilt über das ganze land nach
welchen kriterien wurden die gefunden
die atommüll behälter sollten unter der
erde in einer tiefe von mindestens 300
metern für eine million jahre sicher
lagern also nicht gefährdet seien durch
vulkane oder erdbeben und in
eingeschlossene gesteinsformationen aus
salz ton oder granit müssen am ende
1900 castorbehälter hineinpassen
ein ende der diskussion ist dass heute
also keinesfalls klaus brodbeck aus
berlin
drei jahre haben wissenschaftler in
dieser karte gearbeitet wo könnte in
deutschland atommüll endgelagert werden
und wo nicht
der bislang bekannteste ort dafür fehlt
der salzstock gorleben ist nach
anwendung der geowissenschaftlichen
abwägungs kriterien kein teilgebiet
dafür wenn der zwischenbericht 90 andere
regionen die sich grundsätzlich erst
einmal eignen quer durch deutschland die
bundesdeutsche geologie ist von nord bis
süd und von ost bis west so günstig dass
wir mit überzeugung sagen können dass
sich daraus der eine standort mit der
bestmöglichen sicherheit für die
endlagerung hoch radioaktiver abfälle
wird ermitteln lassen gorleben raus
plötzlich aber auch ein geeigneter
standort in bayern
die regierung in münchen schäumt was wir
nur wollen ist fairness selbst ein
gefühl das diese fairness im moment im
politischen prozess
ein bisschen fehlt nach dem motto am
liebsten alles nach bayern die bayern
soll das nehmen die haben doch mal von
der kernenergie profitieren dabei hatten
die csu im bundestag und die
landesregierung von bayern im bundesrat
dem jetzigen suchprozess zugestimmt
kritiker warnen bayern gefährde das
vertrauen in eine neutrale suche die
suche nach diesem atommülllager also
also nur dann eine chance wenn die
betroffenen überzeugt davon sind dass
dieses verfahren fair und gerecht ist
dass sie denjenigen die suchen und
denjenigen die entscheiden
frauen können ausgerechnet die grünen
atomkraftgegner seit ihrer gründung
drängen nun am entschiedensten auf eine
endlager lösung für den strahlenden müll
man sieht noch einmal was wir da
angerührt haben welche
verantwortungslosigkeit der einstieg in
die atomenergie überhaupt war ja wer
welcher politiker will eine
verantwortung für eine million jahre
übernehmen
das überschreitet jeden horizont in zehn
jahren aber soll die politik einen
standort bestimmen viel zeit für streit
nehmen wir dollar banerjee mit dazu in
berlin nahmen grundlage das was wir
jetzt gerade gesehen haben das ist
erstmal die wissenschaftliche basis aber
wir haben auch gesehen der streit geht
bereits los darum wie geht's jetzt
politisch weiter also eigentlich sollte
sich die politik erst einmal
zurückhalten so war das zumindest
gedacht als dieses verfahren mal
festgelegt worden ist das was heute
vorgestellt wurde war ja nur der
allererste schritt eine grobe skizze
sozusagen mit der man zeigen wollte wo
es sich vielleicht lohnt weiter zu
suchen nach einem geeigneten endlager
ist folgen noch viele weitere schritte
untersuchungen bürgerbeteiligung in
mehreren stufen und am ende soll der
bundestag entscheiden
dagegen kann dann auch noch einmal
geklagt werden also dieses verfahren ist
so angelegt dass alles versucht wird um
möglichst viel transparenz und möglichst
viel akzeptanz daneben auch am ende
herzustellen und so was wie rein
wissenschaftliche wasserdichte daher zu
stellen
wir sehen aber jetzt heute schon dass
die politischen abwehrreflexe
offensichtlich stärker sind als man es
bei verabschiedung dieses war
ahrens gedacht hat das ist kein
besonders gutes zeichen für diese suche
nach einem endgültigen sicheren endlager
für den atommüll der momentan ja seit
jahrzehnten nicht wirklich sicher
gelagert ist ein thema für generationen
schock unter vielen dank großes aufatmen
also bei den atomkraftgegnern in
gorleben was dieser tag für sie bedeutet
zeigt der blick zurück
seit über 40 jahren seit 1977 ist
gorleben als endlager für
hochradioaktiven müll im gespräch
kritiker sagen aus politischen nicht aus
wissenschaftlichen gründen dann 1980
erste probebohrungen im salzstock und
ein protest wie ihn die bundesrepublik
noch nicht gesehen hat die demonstranten
bauen ein hüttendorf rufen die republik
freies wendland aus das dorf wird
geräumt
im salzstock weiter gebaut und die
entscheidung über das endlager immer
wieder aufgeschoben bis jetzt oliver
deuker mit spannung verfolgen mitglieder
der bürgerinitiative umweltschutz
lüchow-dannenberg die pressekonferenz
der bundes gesellschaft für endlagerung
dann fällt der entscheidende satz in
berlin
der salzstock gorleben ist nach
anwendung der geowissenschaftlichen
abwägungs kriterien kein teilgebiet die
skepsis war riesengroß ja immer gedacht
gordon bleibt rückfall option aber
freude ich meine
erstmal ist es ja wichtig dass wir jetzt
auch unsere solidarität zeigt gehen
hingegen über die jetzt in teilgebieten
betroffen sind also das ist ja kein
gewinnerthema
der protest gegen den endlagerstandort
gorleben er formte die eher konservative
ländliche bevölkerung im wendland zu
atomkraftgegnern die sich einmischten
immer wieder quer stellten
generationsübergreifend bis heute ohne
diesen widerstand wäre das
erkundungsbergwerk wahrscheinlich längst
zu einem endlager geworden nun der
schlussstrich unter das kapitel gorleben
wir zeigen hier einfach dass wir nicht
aufgeben und dass wir halt eben mit
unserer kraft auf was schaffen können
das ist wirklich draußen ist nach große
freude rund zwei milliarden euro kostete
die erkundung des salzstocks gorleben
obwohl es von beginn an zweifel an
dessen eignung gab
noch ist unklar was mit dem bergwerk nun
passieren wird und wann die 113 castor
behälter im oberirdischen zwischenlager
gorleben abtransportiert werden bis 2031
soll ein unterirdisches endlager in
deutschland bestimmt sein 2050 dann dort
die einlagerung beginnen so der plan
und so viel zu diesem thema zunächst im
kampf um den vorsitz der cdu gibt es
eine einigung auf einen fahrplan
die drei kandidaten armin laschet
friedrich merz und norbert röttgen
stellen sich zwei öffentlichen live
diskussionen im internet
außerdem soll es noch parteiinterne
einzelgespräche geben
die partei wolle einen fairen wettbewerb
sagt die noch partei chefin annegret
kramp karrenbauer gewählt wird dann auf
dem parteitag am vierten dezember rechte
gewalt rechts rockkonzerte
immobilienkauf durch rechtsradikale die
liste ist lang im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus suchen die
ostdeutschen innenminister jetzt eine
gemeinsame strategie
ein ansatz die verfassungsschutzbehörden
sollen enger zusammenarbeiten auch mit
blick auf die afg cornelia schiemenz hat
die details es sind bilder die verstören
rechtsextreme die brutal gegen
andersdenkende vorgehen die die
bevölkerung verunsichern den umsturz
planen
in leipzig haben sich die ostdeutschen
innenminister vernetzt im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus
wir haben uns heute darauf verständigt
eine arbeitsgruppe einzusetzen
zwischen den ministerien aber auch
zwischen den
landes verfassungsschutzämtern um die
zusammenarbeit zu intensivieren zu
verbessern sondern frühzeitigen
informationsaustausch zu kommen
der bundesverfassungsschutz zählt über
32.000 rechtsextreme deutschlandweit
13.000 davon gewaltorientiert große
rechtsextreme musik und redner
veranstaltungen finden dabei fast
ausschließlich in sachsen und thüringen
statt rechtsextreme versuchen hier zudem
über immobilienkäufe einfluss zu
gewinnen
dort wo immobilien von rechtsextremen
betrieben werden können verfestigten
sich die strukturen und es entsteht ein
netzwerk drumherum deswegen ist es umso
wichtiger dass wir dort dagegen vorgehen
rechtsmotivierte aufmärsche die afg in
erster reihe dabei wie in chemnitz vor
zwei jahren die innenminister
diskutierten awp die afg zum
verdachtsfall
erhoben werden könne wir beobachten sehr
genau im bild haben unseren teil getan
ich werde natürlich einzelheiten aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht sagen dürfen
aber gehen sie davon aus dass wir die
afg sehr genau im fokus haben
möglicherweise könnte eine entscheidung
die afg bundesweit vom verfassungsschutz
beobachten zu lassen noch in diesem jahr
fallen
die afg fraktion im bundestag hat ihren
früheren sprecher christian lüth
fristlos entlassen
hintergrund ist eine prosieben
dokumentation darin soll laut gesagt
haben je schlechter ist deutschland gehe
desto besser für die afd
auch flüchtlinge angesprochen wird der
ehemalige vertraute von fraktionschef
alexander gauland zitiert man könne die
nachher immer noch alle erschießen oder
vergasen lud war bereits im april
beurlaubt worden
der vorwurf in einem gespräch soll er
sich als faschist bezeichnet haben
nach nordrhein-westfalen jetzt beendeten
die kommunalwahlen ja mit stichwahlen
und erstmals erobern die grünen dort
oberbürgermeisterposten nämlich in
aachen bonn und wuppertal in köln
verteidigte die von den grünen und der
cdu unterstützte parteilose
oberbürgermeisterin henriette reker ihr
amt
die spd setzte sich mit thomas westphal
in ihrer traditionellen hochburg
dortmund durch machtwechsel dagegen ihm
zuletzt spd-geführten düsseldorf stefan
keller cdu hat in der landeshauptstadt
gewonnen
unser nächstes thema die gemeldeten
neuinfektionen mit dem corona virus sind
bei uns in deutschland relativ konstant
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 1770 menschen
angesteckt gestern lag der schnitt bei
1730 einen vorgeschmack wie der morgige
corona gipfel mit den
ministerpräsidenten ablaufen könnte
lieferte heute die bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel sorgt sich sehr über die
infektionszahlen auf dem tisch der
vorschlag einer gemeinsamen corona waren
ampel aus berlin andrea bauer
infektionszahlen aktuell so hoch wie
seit april nicht mehr
die kanzlerin hat heute in interner
runde eindringlich vor einem rasant
wachsenden infektionsgeschehen gewarnt
an weihnachten könnte die zahl der
neuinfektionen hochgerechnet bei 19.200
liegen zahlen wie in frankreich so
merkel im kanzleramt wächst die sorge
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass das virus
sich an einzelnen orten wieder
exponentiell ausbreitet wohin das führen
würde das sieht man leider bei einigen
unserer europäischen freunde bundesweite
einheitliche regeln das fordert nun der
bayerische ministerpräsident sein
vorschlag eine verbindliche corona wahn
ampel gelb wenn es in einem landkreis 35
infizierte auf 100000 einwohner gibt
dann kann etwa masken pflicht ab der
fünften klasse angeordnet werden und
bundesliga spiele ohne zuschauer
roth bei 50 infizierten auf 100000
einwohner
dann soll unter anderem die
teilnehmerzahl für private feiern weiter
begrenzt werden und masken pflicht auf
öffentlichen plätzen gelten dürfen mich
ein unendliches täglich sich neue
volieren das regelwerk entwickeln bei
dem am ende keiner mehr durchblickt rum
ist so eine klare regelung werde für
alle aus
bei einer sinnvollen nicht alle aber
finden den vorschlag sinnvoll
die ministerpräsidenten aus sachsen
anhalt und sachsen haben bereits klar
gemacht dass sie keine weiteren
verschärfungen wollen das ist die
ausgangslage für den corona gipfel
zwischen kanzlerin und länderchefs
morgen um 14 uhr per videoschalte
steigende zahlen und die debatte ob es
eine bundesweit einheitliche pandemie
politik braucht oder nicht was passieren
kann wenn krone außer kontrolle gerät
das zeigt sich im moment in spanien
speziell in madrid auf 100000 einwohner
meldet die spanische hauptstadt 721
neuinfektionen in den letzten zwei
wochen
der höchstwert in europa zum vergleich
in berlin waren es unter 50 die ganze
stadt müsse abgeriegelt werden fordert
die linke zentralregierung das könne man
der wirtschaft nicht antun kontert die
rechte regionalregierung und sperrt nur
die am schlimmsten betroffenen gebiete
thomas walde ärztinnen und ärzte in
madrid werfen behörden vor die zweite
corona welle mitverschuldet zu haben
weil sie aus der ersten nicht gelernt
hätten
die hausaufgaben wurden nicht gemacht
obwohl schon nach dem locker und gesagt
wurde dass die lockerungen in spanien
mit einer stärkung des öffentlichen
gesundheitssystems einhergehen müssten
und des gesamten monitoring systems der
kontakt verfolgung
doch statt mehr personal für das
gesundheitswesen gibt es erst einmal
mehr klein klein einige stadtteile
madrids unterliegen einer ausgangssperre
andere nicht
es ergibt keinen sinn weil ein
stadtviertel durch eine straße geteilt
ist auf der einen seite gibt es
beschränkungen auf der anderen nicht ich
sehe da keinen sinn
betroffene stadtteile protestieren die
zentralregierung will die sperre auf die
ganze stadt madrid ausweiten
doch zuständig für das gesundheitswesen
ist die regionalregierung und die will
weniger streng vorgehen um die
wirtschaft zu schonen
was die zentralregierung und hört ich
rate den behörden der regionalregierung
in madrid dringend ihre entscheidungen
zu überdenken und unseren empfehlungen
zu folgen
solange die staatlichen institutionen
ihre reibereien nicht einstellen und das
gesundheitswesen gemeinsam aufrüsten
bleibt die aussicht dass weitere
fähnchen für die opfer der korona krise
in spanien nötig werden
donald trump ist in der jüngeren
geschichte der einzige präsident der nie
seine steuererklärung offengelegt hat
das hat jetzt die new york times getan
und damit mitten im wahlkampf einen
explosiven kugel landet sie zitiert aus
steuerunterlagen von trump und seinen
firmen in den letzten jahrzehnten danach
hat der us präsident über viele jahre
gar keine einkommenssteuer gezahlt
trump selbst sagt der bericht sei falsch
aus washington jutta sonne wollte
donald trumps image als erfolgreicher
geschäftsmann und patriotischer
präsident bröckelt die brisanten
enthüllungen der new york times zu
seinen steuererklärungen und
deklarierten schulden haben den
us-präsidenten gestern kalt erwischt auf
einer pressekonferenz damit konfrontiert
wert trump ab das ist alles fake news
die steuerbehörde behandelt mich einfach
schlecht die new york times beruft sich
auf steuerunterlagen traums der letzten
zwei jahrzehnte und stellt fest in zehn
der 15 jahre sollten überhaupt keine
einkommenssteuer gezahlt haben
im jahr seiner wahl zum präsidenten 2016
und im ersten amtsjahr soll schon nur
750 dollar einkommensteuer bezahlt haben
der durchschnittliche us bürger zeit
laut steuerbehörde 16 mal so viel nicht
transparent er hat schon so oft
versprochen seine steuererklärungen zu
veröffentlichen wie ihn überrascht dass
nun kamp soll dem finanzamt mehr
verluste als einnahmen gemeldet haben
vor allem für seine luxus golf resort
darüber hinaus soll er private ausgaben
als firmen ausgaben deklariert haben zum
beispiel flüge mit seinem privatjet und
ausgaben in höhe von 70.000 dollar für
sein hairstyling für die reality show
the apprentice
das zeigt dass der präsident zwar im
fernsehen einen guten geschäftsmann
spielen konnte aber im echten leben war
es nicht laut new york times prüft die
steuerbehörde irs derzeit eine
bewilligte steuerrückerstattung trumps
sollte die fitch negativ ausgehen müsste
er über 100 millionen dollar an den bund
zurückzahlen
keine guten nachrichten für den
us-präsidenten am tag vor dem ersten
fernseh duell mit seinem herausforderer
joe biden und dieses fernsehduell ist
dann von morgen und übermorgen nacht
unserer zeit erst mal der sport jetzt
mit katja und wieder ist einer weg erst
zwei spieltage ist die aktuelle
bundesliga saison alt und heute wurde
bereits der zweite trainer entlassen
nach david wagner auf schalke gestern
muss jetzt achim beierlorzer bei mainz
05 gehen nach einem fehlstart in der
liga und viel unruhe im verein durch den
spielerstreik der letzten woche als
achim beierlorzer gestern das gelände
verließ war wohl schon klar dass seine
zeit bei den nullfünfern vorbei ist nach
den zwei auftaktniederlagen in der
bundesliga das training hatte er nach
dem 1 4 gegen stuttgart noch geleitet
jetzt ist er raus aber allein damit ist
es wohl nicht getan
mit dem wechsel an der position des
trainers ist unsere analyse der
aktuellen situation nicht abgeschlossen
klingt selbstkritisch diese aussage von
rouven schröder denn auch er hat
vergangene woche bei der degradierung
von stürmer adam solo ii und dem
nachfolgenden trainingsboykott der
mannschaft keine gute figur abgegeben
nun hat er den bisherigen co trainer jan
moritz lichte als chefcoach an seiner
seite für beide gilt es gibt einiges
geradezurücken in mainz zum tennis
gestern haben in paris die french open
begonnen und mitfavorit alexander zverev
hat die erste runde erfolgreich
gemeistert es wäre trotzdem dabei nicht
nur seinem gegner dem österreicher
dennis nowak alexander zverev gut
präpariert gegen nieselregen und kälte
dennoch hatte er zu beginn mit den
bedingungen zu kämpfen und lag gegen den
österreicher nowak schnell eins zu viel
zurück doch er blieb nerven stark bekam
die kurve und gewann satz eins mit 7 zu
5 im zweiten satz legte 12 ein schnelles
break nach und diktierte fortan das
geschehen
die 23 jährige entschied den durchgang
mit starken bei den 6 zu 2 für sich
auch im dritten satz zeigte der
weltranglistensiebte zverev absolute
lockerheit verwandelte nach 2 stunden
und fünf minuten seinen ersten matchball
zum 6 4
ich bin froh dass ich weiter bin und in
der zweiten runde stehen
so kann es weitergehen bei hoffentlich
besserem wetter
das wünschen wir ihm er spielt gegen den
franzosen rbr stichwort besseres wetter
neuer regen im westen bei uns sonst aber
auch sonne die details gleich von özden
terli kurz vor 10 heute abend empfehle
ich ihnen das heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka von uns allen
im team 19 danke fürs zuschauen und bis
morgen
aber erst machen sie sich ein angenehmer
[Musik]
ein schöner name und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter über mitteleuropa tänzeln
zwei tiefs umeinander dass eine lenkt
kühle luft richtung frankreich und das
andere relativ warme luft nach osteuropa
und wir sind in der mitte mit meist
vielen wolken und sogar regen vor allem
westlich des rheins in der nacht hier
halten sich kompakte wolken es regnet
und im südosten ebenfalls regen nach
nord nach norden hin ist es trocken und
teilweise zeigen sich die sterne
bei temperaturen von 4 bis 3 grad von
der norddeutschen tiefebene bis an den
alpenrand sonst 10 bis 11 grad ganz im
westen und im osten sind acht bis zehn
grad morgen am vormittag dann weiterhin
entlang des rheins viele wolken mit
regen auch an den alpen ganz im osten
ebenfalls noch regen teils mit
sonnenschein nach norden zum nachmittag
wandert das regengebiet weiter in die
mitte
nach osten hin bleibt es meist
freundlich teils mit sonnigen
abschnitten temperaturen elf grad an den
alpen 15 bis 18 in anderen regionen und
20 grad im osten deutschlands die
kommenden tage am mittwoch schauer im
westen ansonsten trockenes wetter teils
freundlich 15 bis 21 grad donnerstag
waren bis 22 grad aber weiter regen von
westen her ein schöner abend